if you're not familiar with Elizabeth  she was the founder of an ambitious  biotech company called theranos the  company promised to revolutionize a  blood tests by reducing blood samples to  a single drop of blood but it turned out  that their nose was just one big house  of cards held together with lies and  deception so here's exactly how silicon  Valley's biggest fod was exposed on  October 16 2015 The Wall Street Journal  would post an article titled hot startup  theranos has struggled with its blood  test technology the article revealed how  darnos was only using their  quote-unquote proprietary technology for  a small fraction of their exams and they  continue to collect small blood samples  even for tests that they couldn't  complete and they would simply dilute  these samples and run them through  traditional Machinery as you already  guessed this often resulted in heavily  secured results so they really had  accomplished much of anything